bonjour à tous quel micro utilisé pour
faire vos vidéos youtube il existe plein
de sortes de micros des micro cravate
comme je dis tout de suite pour le début
de la vidéo les idées micro avec fil des
nues quand son fils il ya plein de
choses différentes on va regarder
quelles sont les solutions les plus
simples et les plus utilisés et moi je
vous présenter quatre micros et on va
les tester ensemble pour savoir quel est
le meilleur micro à utiliser
je suis monsieur brochet des vidéos pour
vous aider à réussir sur youtube donne
des conseils et des astuces et fille on
parle aussi de high tech et des produits
qui sont intéressants pour réussir sur
youtube et pouvoir meilleure
productivité et aujourd'hui on se pose
la question des micro avant de commencer
je vous posais la question du jour quel
micro utilisez-vous pour nos vidéos
youtube est-ce que vous avez une marque
préférée
roach rien n'a pas d'autre à cacher
quels sont les micro vous utilisez
quelle est la solution vous préférez
sans fil avec fil plutôt un micro avec
une certaine distance un micro canon
plutôt un micro-cravate mark et moi sans
commentait raymond explique ensemble
aujourd'hui je vous présentais quatre
micros de la marque roda non je ne suis
pas payée par vote par contre j'aime
beaucoup cette marche pour qu'ils ont un
son qui est très sympa j'en utilise déjà
deux sur mes vidéos et je me tâte entre
deux autres le tout premier micro que
j'utilise c'est le vidéo need me le
vidéo mix nuit il se branche sur un
smartphone sur un iphone ou un ipad il
est fait pour ça ressemble à ça c'est un
petit micro que vous avez vous pouvez
régler ici la distance vous brancher
directement sur votre smartphone vous
pouvez brancher un casque directement
ici qui vous sert de moniteurs pour
pouvoir écouter ce que vous avez
enregistré ou en même temps direct ce
que vous enregistrer c'est pas mal c'est
assez pratique vous avez une petite vous
n'êtes anti-vent suffit juste de trouver
l'emplacement que vous mettez là lorsque
vous filmant l'extérieur c'est bien ça
vous protège le son est bien la qualité
est bien par contre l'inconvénient de
stmicro c'est qu'il faut pas être trop
loin
sinon vous perdez en finesse et vous
permet en qualité de sont ensuite aidé à
notre micro qui s'appelle le vidéo micro
qui est celui ci toujours chez rohde qui
est un produit qui est très sympa aussi
moi je lui reproche d'être un truc à ce
micro je le branche sur ma caméra osmo
ici là directement de dj riz c'est très
sympa pareil une bonnette anti-vent un
petit câble jack pour brancher
directement sur votre chien votre caméra
le micro et bien l'inconvénient c'est
que quand vous avez une certaine
distance que perdre est vraiment aussi
en finesse de son et ça c'est un petit
peu le souci de ce micro c'est pour ça
que veut le changer parce que il est
bien lorsque vous êtes prêts lorsque
vous parlez près des goûts vous éloignez
c'est pas ça on perd beaucoup en qualité
ensuite on a notre micro qui est très
sympa que je ne connais pas qu'on va
tester ensemble c'est le vidéo milk de
rhodes
il a la particularité d'avoir un filtre
passe haut c'est à dire que tous les
sons qui sont en dessous de 80 m
donc c'est à dire les sons très très
graves vont être filtrés tous les
parasites et d'avoir aidé son hyper
grave
là dessus on les aura pas il est aussi
trois niveaux sensibilité moins dix
décibels 0 et plus 20 décibels
si nous parle effectivement de khat est
normalement une distance un peu plus
éloignés on va regarder ensemble si on
récupère pas trop de sons parasites
c'est un peu la question que je me pose
pour utiliser on doit avoir une pile 9
volts non fournie avec bien évidemment
une bonne est anti vent et il a une
suspension récolte lire qui lui permet
effectivement pas subir les mouvements
de votre caméra donc ça n'a pas
parasiter l'enregistrement c'est un
micro qui est super cardioid et puis le
dernier micro qui peut aussi être
intéressant c'est le vide et au micro de
rhodes violet sur un produit qui agit
pour le broadcast donc vraiment probant
vraiment la meilleure qualité ce aussi
parmi ces quatre produits le produit le
plus cher
il a la même suspension que vous allez
retrouver sur le vidéo micro et sur le
vidéo milk savoir la rigotte lire il a
une garantie 10 ans lui aussi une
garantie 10 ans deux ont une garantie 1
an qu'on peut monter jusqu'à 2 en hausse
enregistrée en ligne il fonctionne avec
une pile vous pouvez l'utiliser pendant
soixante dix heures avec la pile
celui ci pendant 100 heures avec la pile
donc j'ose imaginer que celui ci est un
petit peu plus gourmand pareil transit
votre sélection
- 10 décibels zéro + 20 décibels le
micro est fière d'être un peu plus
petits plus discret que le vidéo milk
alors moi ce que je vous propose c'est
que pour voir exactement et avoir un
vrai comparatif on va les brancher
directement sur la caméra
à cette distance là là je dois être
quelque chose comme 50 cm de la caméra
et après on va l'éloigner
on va se mettre plus loin et on verra ce
que ça dit à un mètre voire 1 mètre 50
pour voir si on a une différence de son
1 2 3 pete est avec mont vidéo micro
mégot jeté 10 depuis déjà un bon petit
moment ans auquel j'ai fait énormément
de vidéos avant même de partir son
micro-cravate serait que ce micro est
plutôt pas mal par contre en terme de
précision sonore on a une précision qui
est beaucoup moins bonne que sur le
vidéo milk et que sur le vidéo mais pro
par contre ne lisais avec une distance
assez proches c'est un micro qui se
tient bien en gros faut parler là là si
je parle là normalement en termes de
qualité je suis mieux dès que je
m'éloigne je perd en précision du son et
je vais récupérer un petit peu des sons
ambiants
là normalement je devrais avoir un son
un peu plus directionnels ça devrait
être beaucoup plus simple normalement là
je dois avoir un bon son jeu suit à
distance
on va tester maintenant le tout dernier
micro qui est le vidéo pro et maintenant
j'essaye de vidéo micro qui est branché
directement ici qui a l'air d'être pas
mal à lens celui-là c'est plus simple
contrairement aux vidéos mythe qui a 1 3
niveaux de sélection comme je le disais
moins dix décibels 0 décibels est plus
un décibel
celui ci aussi là également par contre
celui là on le trouve bien moins
facilement c'est à dire qu'on va le
modifier à l'intérieur donc on accepte
moins facilement que sur le vidéo micro
le vidéo mise pro vous avez le sélecteur
derrière d'un bouton avec vos trois
niveaux de sélection donc là je suis sur
le niveau zéro dont je suis sur un
niveau flat maintenant je vais passer
sur le moins dix ne rapproche pas ce que
je pense que si je me mets là on n'a
plus beaucoup de sons maintenant on va
essayer le plus avoir à lâcher ça c'est
le produit le plus cher que j'ai dans
l'es4 c'est un produit qui coûte un
petit peu moins de 200 euros
si on résume le prix la vidéo me cmi
coûte aux alentours de 60 euros
d'ailleurs je vous mettrai tous les
liens description moi si ça vous
intéresse pour aller voir celui là 59
euros 90 le vidéo mik
on est entre 89 euros et 109 euros ça
dépendrait ce que vous l'achetiez si
elle est promue y venons le vidéo micro
on est entre 185 euros et 199 euros
maintenant ce qu'on va faire c'est que
on va le mettre
une distance un petit peu plus lointaine
pour écouter la différence donc là je
suis un médecin quand je suis avec le
vidéo need pro pour l'instant je suis
sur un niveau à 0 décibels je vais le
mettre sur le plus 20 décibels pour moi
la voie en tout cas j'adore jusqu'au
logo solange et même la personne est
dans le rouge
donc là on est sur la vidéo mik je suis
un niveau zéro décibels ce que je
croyais vraiment mal dans ce micro c'est
pour accéder au sélecteur 0 décibels il
faut enlever la pile et ça c'est super
relou me voilà de retour sur mon micro
le vidéo micro que j'utilise depuis
quelques temps alors le problème en
harris avec la précision du son ces
distances parce que je récupère vraiment
le son de la pièce on l'a jamais mon
petit micro cravate
ici un petit audio technica d'ailleurs
je voudrais bien dans la description ci
voulait jeter un coup d'oeil c'est
pratique c'est pas cher j'ai trouvé ça
sur sur amazon c'est vraiment un produit
qui est pas cher vous avez deux petites
piscines intérieures et ces pratiques
alors là je leur mets juste pour qu'on
puisse regarder les différents produits
ensemble ça c'est le micro que j'utilise
habituellement il est plutôt pas mal
mais comme je voulais tout à l'heure des
vous avez une certaine distance on perd
en précision et en perd en finesse de
son et c'est vraiment ce que je reproche
à ce produit ont appris ils vont un
petit peu moins de 60 euros si vous êtes
à une distance qui est raisonnable que
vous tenez votre caméra à la main pour
du blog pour des choses vraiment d'une
petite proximité c'est pas mal le son
est plutôt bien fait maintenant moi
j'hésite entre deux produits j'avais
d'un côté le vidéo milk qui est pas mal
de chez road est de notre côté
le vidéo milk prend le profit d omid pro
vous avez tout en haut le bouton pour
l'allumer avec le koup bas et en dessous
vous avez la ténue acteurs atténuateur
je voulais dire c'est dur
zéro et plus on a un accès très rapide
très pratique en fonction de la
situation dans laquelle vous êtes vous
pouvez modifier très très facilement
vous adapter et une vraie modularité
il est compact il est quand même
beaucoup plus petit tiens beaucoup moins
de place sur votre caméra
maintenant celui là et que je leur
prends déjà dans sa bataille il a un
encombrement qui est énorme
vous avez effectivement ainsi accès à
votre bouton avec votre coup bas ici
maintenant le vrai problème ici vous
avez la place pour mettre la pile vous
avez juste ici là à l'intérieur les
différentes positions pour calibrer
votre micro et pour le maître comme vous
souhaitez et ça c'est un vrai vrai vrai
vrai vrai problème ce qui fait que
lorsqu'on est en situation réelle il
vous est strictement impossible de
changer la sensibilité de votre mission
vous pouvez pas le mettre à -10 à zéro
ou à plus d'un délai comme vous le
souhaitez vous devez forcément enlever
le cash enlever la pile de cet espèce de
petit réglage avec des mini bouton a
poussé avec un espèce de kurdes enfin
c'est vraiment pas pratique
alors au final quel micro choisir parmi
tout ce que je vous ai présenté je suis
en réalité un petit peu embêté parce que
vous a présenté des micros entre 60
euros est quasiment 200 euros et au
final je trouve que la meilleure qualité
sonore gelé avec mon micro cravate avec
mon audio technica avec un fil par
contre alors celui-ci effectivement ma
tombe malade et c'est pas un micro hf si
je voulais l'équivalent sherrod il y en
a pour trois cent cinquante euros
allez jeter un petit break parce que le
produit sympa si vous devez investir ça
vaut le coup de regarder je vous mets
aussi à garder la description le
technique à celui ci je voulais me aussi
en lien il va coûter peut-être 20 30
euros par contre je trouve que mon micro
à 20 euros pour les vidéos que je fais
comme ça à ses distances il a pour moi
un meilleur son et une meilleure
précision que le vidéo micro de chez
rohde à 200 euros nous avoir tous
essayer tous écouté fait un tour complet
ces deux micros là pour moi sont les
meilleurs dès lors qu'on veut un micro
autre qu'un micro cravate si vous voulez
celui là il est plutôt pas mal par
contre vous allez perdre vraiment
précision si on veut de la précision ces
deux là sont bien si on veut pouvoir
régler je dirais le niveau
bien c'est à dire choisir votre votre
niveau de décibels le vidéo micro c'est
celui qu'il vous faut si vous avez un
iphone ou un ipad vous prenez le vidéo
me cmi et qui est très très pratique
mais uniquement pour un iphone ou un
ipad
si vous êtes à une distance très faible
vous pouvez utiliser la vidéo micro
sinon si vous avez les distances qui
sont supérieures à 20 30 40 50 cm
utiliser le vidéo micro ou le vidéo
micro qui pour moi ont des bonnes
précision mais c'est vrai que dans
l'absolu
en dehors de tous ces micros qui vont
coûter 100 euros 200 euros
mon micro cravate à 20 euros 30 euros
franchement il fait bien mieux le jazz
pourquoi tout simplement parce que j'ai
une vraie proximité entre ma voix ma
bouche et le micro qui fait que j'ai pas
les problèmes de son psg pas tous les
problèmes de distance c'est vraiment là
où j'ai une meilleure chance par contre
la chine seul à parler mais si vous
voulez faire voir d'autres intervenants
il vous faut un autre micro pour avoir
un super rapport qualité prix pour moi
celui ci il est super dès lors vous avez
pas besoin de changer votre bien c'est
je pense un super compromis si
maintenant vous voulez vous amuser
changer votre bien et que vous avez
besoin de différents niveaux sonores
celui-ci marche très bien je trouve que
si on utilise par exemple à 0 décibels
c'est un produit qui va coûter du simple
au double 11 pas que ce soit forcément
justifié celui ci le vidéo milk fait un
super boulot celui ci a pas d'option
fait un bon boulot mais je trouve qu'il
ya pas un écart aussi énorme que s'en
retrouve les deux produits dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en commentaires si
vous avez déjà essayé si vous avez des
amis sur sept produits
mark et moi tout en bas et puis on va en
discuter puis toujours hyper intéressant
d'avoir différents retours d'expérience
mais à mon sens si vous voulez
solutionner vos primes de son le plus
important c'est d'avoir le micro le plus
près de la source
la source est votre bouche un
micro-cravate vous êtes proche alors
après il en existe son fils vous avez
des sénateurs mais ça va vous coûter un
petit peu moins de 1000 euros c'est
quand même cher jeudi chez roth vous
avez un produit qui est bien son fils
que je vous conseille d'aller voir qui
marche bien qu'il ya une super qualité
qui sera supérieur à celui ci mais qui
par contre va être en termes de prix est
beaucoup plus élevé merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo je vous invite à vous
abonner à ma chaîne parce qu'il y avait
encore plus de vidéos pour réussir sur
youtube pour trouver les bons produits
est les produits d'affluence qui vous
aideront dans votre vie tous les jeux
merci beaucoup abonnez-vous si la vidéo
vous a plu cette année c'est des jolies
pousse dans le hot spot à moi je vous
dis à très bientôt pour de prochaines
vidéos salut